we barely made a dent in the divorce
rate in the United States we continue to
talk about you know so many of my
religious friends tell me oh gay
marriage these gays are going to ruin
heterosexual marriage and I say to them
don't worry about that this there's
nothing left to ruin we straight people
have done a fine job destroying marriage
already I know that religion needs rules
because without rules religion becomes a
mockery but the love and the rules have
to coexist so for example here in the
United States the two the two great
religious battle grounds have been
abortion and have been gay marriage
there are so many ways to make those
issues inclusive without religion
compromising it stands for example you
can tell gay men and women that because
the Bible says that homosexuality is
unacceptable that we can't necessarily
condone homosexuality having said that
we love you you're equally gods trials
and there's so many other virtues you
have that you go that we probably don't
have come to church and pray we love you
come to synagogue and pray no one's
going to judge you by your legs I'm not
going to talk about it instead we say
what if you're gay should you be coming
to church that's terrible and that's
that's terrible to exclude people based
on any kind of choice like that or
abortion why we made abortion into such
a profoundly divisive issue which is a
bit which is a debate on the origin of
life we really should have made it an
inclusive issue which is a debate about
famine and dignity ninety-nine percent
of all abortions are women who are
bedded by men don't love them who
impregnate them and then shedding any
kind of responsibility just leave them
by themselves that's not a religious
issue that's a social responsibility
radical left-wing feminists and
right-wing Catholic should be on the
same page about this one again not about
abortion but in telling women don't let
men take advantage of you value yourself
go into a relationship where you demand
and expect real intimacy real well
and